[Music]
why are you playing the national anthem
oh cause you're condos in america
[Music]
dunder mifflin this is pam
i'm sorry he's not in yet would you like
his voicemail
yeah yeah
yeah okay
12 miles an hour eat that call lewis
angela made several 911 calls about cars
going too fast in front of the building
so the police put up a radar gun
it's actually caused a bit of a traffic
hazard
[Music]
wow 13 no no no
there was wind i was just jogging dwight
there was wind
i want to do all right it's not your
turn all right 13 is the new number
oscar go ahead i want another try here
we go
31 31 there was the car
i was ahead of the car 31 is my new
number 31 is humanly impossible go
oscar 31 is my number that's impossible
beat it
look at that huh nice i love
cycling andy i feel like a tourist in my
own city i literally can't wait to wake
up every morning okay
she is a cute can't beat a horse a horse
is a bike that pedals itself yes it is
oh
look at that smooth roll yeah you got it
lance armstrong's bike
yes his ass was on that seat all right
nice oh meredith it's not his actual
bicycle but it is the same exact model
he uses
i'm on trail crow's side in that whole
thing so i feel really weird right now
michael oh god oh yes i can ride a bike
i take spinning classes three times a
month
i think i know how to ride a bike are
you sure you once knew how to do this i
did
yes i had those extra wheels on the back
that
support you my goal my michael
michael michael my god
just steer more now oh my god
you never forget
oh for god's sake
planking is a very stupid and dangerous
trend basically you lie like a plank in
weird places
that's it sometimes you get run over
welcome to the internet planking is one
of those things where
hey you either get it or you don't
i don't but i am so excited to be a part
of it
smart right very smart
this has got to stop i can't get down
okay
kevin oh it's time aloft
come on daryl lift lift daryl
yeah i wanted to manage the job but i
got something much
better this soda
this is mine it might be easy if you
take a deep breath
lift from the knees and shove it up your
butt
kids don't try planking it's dangerous
especially with me around
no hey
michael what are you doing here
did you come back for us or i can't
finish
i feel so weak i just we probably
dehydrated what do you want me to do jim
glass of water would be a star no there
are people
all over the world with all sorts of
problems and afflictions
and diseases they're deformed
and they're abnormal and they're
illiterate and ugly symphonies don't
have any money
public tv is bust i can't do anything
about it i can't you know
there's just one of me and there's a
thousand
of them and rabies wins
wow you are a downer
we were having a pretty nice day i'm
still having a nice day you are yeah
hey michael look at this lamp eight
dollars
that's a good deal
and michael you don't have rabies
and chances are you're not gonna get it
anytime soon
so you don't really have to think about
it too much
pam if everybody felt that way nothing
would get done
yeah but there's other better people out
there who are helping
you just don't think i am capable of
making a difference
i know you michael i saw you naked
you don't you don't know me
you've just seen my penis i can't make a
difference
remember i'm the one who started this
whole thing off by hitting meredith with
my car
and i owe it to her to finish his
gd5k oh
no no hmm
finishing that 5k was the hardest thing
i have ever had to do
i ate more fettuccine alfredo and drank
less water than i have in my entire life
[Applause]
people always talk about triumphs of the
human spirit
well today i had a triumph
of the human body that's why everybody
was applauding for me at the end
my guts my heart
[Applause]
and while i eventually puked my guts out
i
never puked my heart out
and i'm very very proud of that
god go tell somebody what andy
andy what should i tell them don't tell
them i'm floating away obviously
i don't understand what you want from me
angela it's pretty simple
look at what i'm doing and go tell
somebody it
sorry ah bye andy
this is parkour internet sensation of
2004
and it was in one of the bond films it's
pretty impressive the goal is to get
from point a to point b
as creatively as possible so technically
they are doing parkour
as long as point a is dilution and point
b is the hospital
[Applause]
okay
jump over the camera jump over the
camera
okay we all go together or we go one at
a time here it is here it is
uh truck to refrigerators to dumpster
360 spin onto the palace backflip gainer
into the trash can
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah hardcore
parkour
i'm right behind you andy come on yeah
parkour
what's this these are the closing
ceremonies
step up um
here on the top congratulations to
michael
because he closed on his condo so gold
medal
i don't really know what to say
um
not one for making speeches but uh
my heart is very full at this moment
and for dwight schrute the silver medal
get up here dwight
[Applause]
silver metal yeah not as good as gold
[Music]
why are you playing the national anthem
oh
cause you're condos in america
[Music]
what the hell is that those are the
doves
all right
you